these villagers thought they were safe
after escaping the tsunami that tore
into the western coast of Java but now
they've returned they face a new problem
around 6:00 in the morning the water
began rising I went out to get some food
and when I came back the water was
almost chest high our village has never
been flooded like this
Jonny moved his family because of the
risk of another tsunami behind me with
his wife three other children and 25
other individuals it's a tight squeeze
he says but at least he's living with
the comfort of loved ones and they're
all accounted for right now all he has
faced his family Johnny's wife may
sorrow remembers the moment she had to
leave when I heard talk of a second
tsunami coming
I grabbed my children and ran to my
sister's house people were panicking and
fleeing screaming run run because the
wave was coming I couldn't think of
anything else the safety of my children
was my only priority
my youngest children are eight and three
years old they're in a bit of a shock
can have trouble sleeping so although
the tsunami spared this family the flood
still threatened their lives
you